i'm joined now by zanesh hussain who
lives in harrison with his family who's
saying thank you so much for talking to
us this evening
what's the situation where you are now
okay the city is pretty silent right now
but uh since i saw the tanks outside
this morning the russian military forces
i haven't seen anything from the
ukrainian organizations after that i
mean no police there is no ukrainian
military here
so i believe that the city is in 100
in
uh ukrainian russian control actually
and then i saw this post from the city
administration the mayor of the city
this evening that their negotiating and
this post is mentioning that he's not
getting any help from the ukraine
government and then you put some
conditions like the curfew hours for
example
uh you're not supposed to go out after
six o'clock you cannot have a gathering
of more than three people together
uh you are supposed to drive at the
minimal speed so life is getting
normal a bit that way but the city is
definitely under russian control there
is no ukrainian control here
so when you look outside what do you see
so far there is nothing but occasionally
you see the russian patrolling cars
that's
twice an hour approximately like you
will this is this routine you will see a
truck or a jeep
and they're on patrolling like there
were tanks this morning but it's not
that way i mean they're just controlling
the entry and exit points now
and the occasional patrolling weather
russian cars there are no skills
do you hear anything hussein
its pen drops silent and that's what
makes us worry because usually when
there is silence there is something bad
is going to happen usually i mean
looking at the last one week
so you think
as as i was saying you know throughout
the day and this evening even now in the
last couple of minutes we've had these
conflicting reports over who controls
the city who do you think controls it
i think ukraine has no control over the
city this is 100
under russian control i'm very sure
about that
okay so
just explain to us you live there with
your wife and your child
what is it like for you
it's terrifying i mean having a three
years old daughter who is locked up and
you're just trying to keep her away from
this but it's kind of hard i mean
keeping her busy with the cartoons and
putting earphones
just that she does not hear the noises
that are coming from outside
and this war has been pretty traumatic
because
we have been told from last couple of
months that there will be no war and we
should not worry and we don't need to
panic
uh but things dramatically change i mean
the day it all started i slept i had
plans for the next day we had no idea
this is gonna happen and then uh when
they woke up in morning everything was
upside down obviously and then four or
five days it was like that but we didn't
see anything with our eyes we were
hearing loud bangs just uh you know from
from a far distance like but uh today i
when i woke up with a lot of bangs
outside i just uh opened up my window
and i saw like the tanks that are
literally standing 10 meters away from
my house and there's soldiers they're
firing morning shorts
just telling civilians to go back in and
there are people running on the street
it was horrifying and definitely being
here with the family this is one of the
most horrifying experience that i have
actually
do you have supplies
it is a huge issue i mean the supplies
itself uh
i have mentioned that before on my
social media actually that the banks
they don't have cash anymore and the
banks are not trusted by the couple of
small businesses i mean the small stores
that are open
the shelves are empty there are hundreds
of people studying the queue if you want
to buy something you don't have a choice
anymore like you will just go there you
will grab the first thing that you will
see
and
and even based upon that like i have
supplies for like next 24 hours maximum
and if the city doesn't open it that
life doesn't get normal here i have no
idea what i'm gonna do actually do you
have food in your flat
uh that's for the next 24 hours and me
and my wife we have been uh you know
water fasting so that our
daughter have enough
uh
just explain explain what that means to
us hussain
i just like i mean we are not eating a
lot just we uh keep ourselves hydrated
with a lot of water and
we're leaving maximum for the daughter
so that she can eat that uh because
they're not sure actually i mean i i
went out for an hour this
uh
afternoon actually so that looking for
some groceries couldn't find much
actually just a bit so what what was
that like can you just explain what that
was like to us when you walked out onto
the streets of the city what was open
who was around what did you see okay um
there were a couple of hours when there
was no military outside and
the civilians were walking out of it
that's that's like in the early
afternoon hours
uh everything was closed actually
supermarkets they're the large chain
stores here like atp and fresh they were
closed
uh
the drugstores they were closed and
there were just a couple of small stores
that were open they were crowded like
hundreds of people in there the shelves
were empty
they do not accept any bank cards cash
is a problem in the city actually things
are the prices have tripled down i will
say
and i understand that these
small businesses they do not have access
to the supplies themselves so
because the city is built completely
uh it was horrifying it's just like it's
not the same city that that have left
like for one and a half years different
and the russians you said that you saw
russians on the tanks were they telling
the civilians anything were they giving
any directions was there any
communication
so they just entered the street and they
started fighting these warning shots
with their guns just pointing towards
the sky and there was more like a
warning like get inside to your houses
or we're going to shoot you
and when this happened civilians were
running the streets were empty within
minutes actually like there was no one
in the street and they just stayed there
for for an hour or two
then the regular petrols this is how it
has been
at any point it's seven days in now this
invasion at any point did you want to to
leave
your city and leave the country
um
as i said like the war began as a
complete i will say like uh
you know we were not expecting this to
happen
and
for the next couple of days we heard
these sounds from a distance and
it looked like like it's i mean we're
not seeing the war with our eyes it was
like something is happening at a
distance and maybe they will stop
maybe they will uh the ukrainians will
fight and they won't enter the city but
when when i saw the tanks this morning
the death was like a
sticking point like i can't take this
anymore because i realize that it is
over like no one is going to kind of
rescue us here and i think it's the
right moment to leave yeah
okay um hussein a lot well
men between 18 and 60 they're not
allowed over the borders obviously
because of conscription we've seen so
many people so many civilians take up
arms and fight these the invading forces
have you wanted to do that have you
tried to do that have people in your
city try to do that
there was a bit of difference i mean we
saw what people are doing in kiev like i
mean the civilians they are armed there
and they are trying to protect their
city
and we had this inspiration like sort of
thing that motivates you to go but uh
myself a lot of my friends who contacted
the new military units that we were told
that there are no weapons for us
because they're waiting for the weapons
from the cave and from the west
uh so the civilians that's why there was
no retaliation from the civilians when
the when the russian military entered
inside the city because we were not uh
given any weapons we were not made ready
for this just like
he has he the residents of here they are
being prepared for this and even in the
hierarchy i have seen that but here is a
different story we were not ready at all
we don't have weapons no one paid
attention actually we have been told
that the last day that no one is going
to enter the city they're going to win
this poor
but it was sort of untrue yeah
okay just very briefly hussain how are
you going to try and get out
this another issue i mean the first
thing is that the the russians are
heading to the mik live which is a city
close to like almost 30 40 kilometers
from here
but it's pretty narrow road like you
don't have an other choice i mean you
have to pass through a road and there
are russians over there and there are
there i don't know if there are rumors
or there have been reports over the
social media that people are getting
short we are trying to leave
so
and on top of that leaving the city and
they control the entry and exit points
then no one is willing to drive us uh
to the
i mean the rest border will take us
maybe 18 to 24 hours
no one is willing to drive and those are
willing to trade they're asking for like
five to seven thousand dollars for that
on a normal day i will not even pay 500
for this ride
i have been contacted but
i've been contacted by a lot of people
on social media like someone has family
stuck there there is a young man warren
who is based in
netherlands he wants to get his
mother-in-law out she's i think 54 years
old woman she's alone in the city so
there are a lot of people i mean from
india they are
they want my
help with the evacuation process
so we are trying to organize our group
actually so that we can leave
feel that that might be safe for us yeah